so very briefly are made I look right
provider transatlantic perspective and
focusing on first the similarities
between the situation in the United
States and frost and then also important
differences between two countries so
when I was thinking about this debate
and I'm very grateful for the invitation
they were not always
I was thinking okay Apple oranges yes
and no so I tried to address this this
question so I distant first some
similarities and most of the similarity
design distant relate to the
securitization of communication issues
on both sides of the Atlantic and the
subsequent new form of politicization of
three conditions in America and impulse
buy securitization of immigration when
with something intimate barbarians but I
name the framing of immigration as a
security issue being that immigrants
broadly defined on both sides of the
Atlantic independently from their legal
status we go in
even a new covers first generation
member realistic and third generation
all of them are received as the threat
to national prosperity national identity
and national moves safety and this is
what we call my room mobile and this is
where I slightly disagree with a
personal I think that in the United
States when we think about immigrants
are even thinks about Mexicans but the
second thing is illegal hispanic and if
you're illegal you're a criminal so i
think there is a strong correlation
between the immigration in the united
states and criminality doing that of
course there is plenty of evidence that
immigration of hispanics but also other
minorities immigration does not do twist
criminology the problem is that we are
does not matter when it comes to same
phobia and our migrant phobia so this I
think on both sides of this migrant
opium is you by the overestimation of
graduation scale and to the rhetoric of
invasion and mention that of course if
we compare the movies where a mateur in
from various small remindin communities
but in fact it doesn't matter what
really mattered is notion of Monica's
threat and there is not straightforward
correlation between the size of my own
communities and the level of ethnic
exorcism you can have you know very high
level one ethnic citizen in state or
region localities where you have only
its movement minding convince and so
this is the overestimation of migration
cell and we have they are about that
average both American and French tent
i estimate the number of foreigners once
again whom we defined by twenty-five
percent and there is also I think a
common assumption that newcomers are too
far in two different to a sealant and
there is in conjunction with this
universe without innovation flows and
under estimation of migrant and minority
integration and because despite
discrimination and Aaron not dismissing
discrimination frost in indication in in
the bigger market and so on the despite
everything my groups are more integrated
than expected and this is I think on
similar in the US where he studied I'm
sorry Thank perfectly friend in English
around specially the second not to
mention her generation so sorry for
Huntington that
perfectly assimilated so this is why I
called the sea characterization of
immigration issues and this trend
predated mighty measurement of course
911 push through this app framing of
collaboration as a security issue on
both sides of the Atlantic and the main
lectures are public discourse major
coverage spreading negative perception
of ingress negative stereotypes are
shared by the significant portion of
books American French public opinion
that immigrants are working for the
economy that they don't have missing
values threat to national identity and
therefore to national safety and and the
end to national security and also I
think there are stronger vertices
between public policies those
implemented after 911 and this is one
include the blurring of the distinction
between three
policies and counter-terrorist policies
immigration policies used as a way to
prevent terrorism and also to control
minority groups and contact terrorists
policies supposed to innate migration
flows out in both case we speak it
didn't work is not working it's not
going to work and it's counterproductive
and also by securitization I think it's
worth noting that racial profiling and
discrimination against many different
minorities on both sides of the Atlantic
are all justified by the necessity to
protect the nation and the nation so
infringement of civil liberties
violation of human rights everything
based on the distinction between us fed
us and then in this security context
seconds malaria listed how is the new
walls of politicization of immigration
issues which affect immigration policies
immigration politics and also
integration policy because it's time to
say
immigrants age you know and at some
point they also be citizen of the remedy
and so we are we dealing with newcomers
with foreigners but we also giving with
an increasing number of people were born
in the US and therefore American citizen
all the member of the second or third
generation in house so this
politicization of migration issues the
main vector R nativism and is enough
phobia and I was quite surprised but
maybe because of the French perspective
by the notification not at the federal
level that at the state level in this
country the multiplication of French
style controversies very fine design
conferences issues such as binding
wisdom the anchor babies controversy
which is very French I mean you're not
over the top you don't have a good mind
to become automatically citizen just
because you born in the country this is
very French
the opposition to ground 0 mosque which
was not most by the way but anyway
they're also another series in Wisconsin
Georgia and Kenji and the ultimate
example for me was on burning pain
novica i know are safe or if I'm elected
are there was no Muslim at the White
House I think it was you know the cherry
on the top of the poison cake and I was
very surprised by the knack of the
action I thought it by the end of his
political career actually due to the
gown and they say but I was quite
surprised because of you know sticking
so all the verses that why the politics
of immigration remain different in the
United
past I think there are strong silent
colleges in terms of listed properties
articulate about me for electric
purposes not to mention that our our
president will sign on atlantic face
similar challenges economic distress
political distrust and integration
issues are the most radical integration
is should be the emergence of on ground
terms however having said that very
brief able to list our differences and
here are more optimistic may be done
with a sumo and i think that the
American system remains more open than
different one and this American openness
can be explained that three factors that
are either week or insignificant in
France the first one is the
institutional framework the little own
system for better or worse in this
country it's very difficult if not
impossible to reform immigration system
so the good news is that restrictive
missed attempt and strengthen border
control
they're also all the attempt to have a
more comprehensive immigration reform so
it's you know it works both ways and
second the second reason its second
actor through my new interest groups and
migrant movies I'll have an impact on
buitin defamation open immigration
policy is all that is reported in this
country by a various economic interest
group and in the right is still waiting
for an educated debate in France about
the benefits of immigration at someone
someone has to pay for pension and
finally the science of migrant
communities of size matter especially at
the congressional district level there
are strong incentive of political our
leaders three cemeteries in this country
to attract our the vote of ethnic
minorities in France there is absolutely
no incentive they can you know just
dismiss the claims from
form of minority groups and so on and
there is no significant groups
advocating the expansion of imitation no
incentive to port ethnic voters
therefore there is no ethnic politics
are there was debate about the masking
boat few days owning the pole of most
people to against our cuisine but there
is no Muslim world even the guest
services as as a result ethnic minority
population are not politically visible
and we can be quite rather pessimistic
about in the opportunities for them to
find otherwise